[Music]
this is your first SAG Award yes this is
special tonight for me because I didn't
expect and and I appreciate because I
know actors understand what it is we do
for them to say hey we recognize and I
appreciate what you did I'm really moved
but how about that support from vilest
that's my girl I love it she's a
brilliant brilliant actor and it's her
turn now yeah the actor has met the role
now and she deserves everything she's
good you have more Oscar nominations
than any other african-american actor
ever does that mean to you it's
beautiful I mean you know it means that
I've because of the people that came
before me I've had the opportunity to
get better scripts and therefore get the
chances to win because of the Sydney
party airs and James Earl Jones is and
on and on all the way back because they
laid the groundwork I have the
opportunity to do this somebody up there
tonight or in this whole cycle I'll
leave or one of the other guys one day
going to do more to me they set it up
for me now I've set it up for the next
[Music]